hey guys it's dr. Berg here I wanted to
create a video on how what to do to
actually handle this skin problem here
and here there are things you can do but
there's some mistakes that people make
the first thing you need to know is that
hormonal e at age 38 things start
shifting in the body now over a period
of a few more years when you hit 50 now
things really bottomed out so during the
menopause it's a time period which is
actually 52 but it can happen like 48 it
can happen 56 hormonal e the ovaries
stop working okay so there's a back up
organ and the back of organ is the
adrenals on top of the kidney you have
two of them and so you have this huge
shift from ovarian hormones to adrenal
hormones okay if there's any problem
with those adrenals before menopause
everything is magnified you get hot
flashes you have bone loss you have a
lot of loose skin things like that but
really this is a loss of collagen okay
and that comes from a loss of certain
hormones so I'm going to explain what
hormones all of these hormones decrease
during menopause testosterone which is
more lean body mass DHEA that's an anti
stress hormone that's kind of like a a
pre hormone that gives you all the other
hormones and it's made by the adrenal
gland and then you have estrogen that
goes down and estrogen controls the
fertility and the menstrual cycle and
all that and then progesterone
progesterone also goes down that also
involved involved in the second half of
the menstrual cycle and the estrogen
progesterone work together so when one
goes down they should be in certain
ratios so when women are after menopause
are considered estrogen dominant which
is kind of weird because it goes down
what they mean is the relative ratio of
estrogen to progesterone is off so even
though estrogen goes down a little bit
progesterone really goes down well so
that would be create a situation when
your estrogen dominant very similar to
if you were to like take I don't know
sodium and salt and potassium they work
together so if you have too much salt
and not enough potassium
you get fluid or tension but if you have
a what you can do is you can lower salt
but you can also raise potassium and get
rid of the fluid that way instead of
just avoiding the salt so there's in
other words there's this ratios you have
to look at okay and these work together
but the big one that really messes
people up and that's responsible for the
loose skin is this growth hormones
called human growth hormone now in a in
a child it's mainly responsible for the
growth of the child okay but when you
become an adult
it doesn't make you keep growing it
controls other things
fat burning tight muscles energy
collagen all the protein synthesis or
creation of proteins hair nail skin
muscle all that so growth hormone is the
really the one that goes down as you age
unfortunately so there are people that
actually take growth hormone as a
supplement it doesn't work unless you're
injected by an actual growth hormone on
a synthetic growth hormone that will
work and that will actually help with
your weight loss lean body mass and it's
an anti-aging thing but it has some
slight minor side effects it's very
expensive it's like $15,000 for every
six weeks okay and then number two if
you take it over a period of time your
own glands shut down and you become
dependent on it and then you take more
and you get side effects like diabetes
so there's a lot of problems with taking
hormones and that's why I would only
recommend taking it's the last resort
and you get people taking HRT hormone
replacement therapy biochemical hormones
which again if you take those you're
going to create a lot of confusion in
the different organs so you're going to
any Ormeau new hormone you take you
indirectly shut down the gland that's
supposed to produce it so you basically
put everything asleep same thing with
the thyroid you take it over period of
time and then thyroid doesn't have to
produce anymore okay so now when we have
growth hormone that goes down this is
the buffer this is the opposing hormone
to cortisol cortisol is the stress
hormone from the adrenal that's the one
that's very destructive on your protein
so if that's too high you get your body
become
what's called a catabolic state or a
cannibalistic it breaks down proteins
faster than its building back up so you
get loss of muscle protein in your
thighs and your butt yet you get loose
skin here and here not a great site
saggy skin in your belly
so really the loose skin is a
combination of not enough growth hormone
and too much cortisol but remember
cortisol might test pause
but the ratio is very very high cortisol
low growth hormone so even though it's
normal it has nothing to oppose it it's
nothing to buffer it there's nothing to
kind of minimize it so it's just a free
cortisol that goes out there and
destroys everything so that's it's too
much of this and not enough of this so
the next part I'm going to show you what
to do about this situation so check this
out all right now over here we have
things to lower cortisol over here we
want to raise growth hormone okay so
let's just kind of go back and forth
cortisol is triggered by stress so
everything we're going to do is going to
reduce stress number one low intensive X
intensity exercise that would be like
walking now over here you have to raise
the high intensity because full body
high intensity exercise will increase
growth hormone the problem is if you're
in adrenal body type you you can't do
this yet so you're going to have to do
walking for a period of time because
just because you're an adrenal body type
doesn't mean you're always going to be
an adrenal type you want to get out of
that type and shift over here to be able
to increase the growth hormone but we
have to get you sleeping first to be
able to handle this intensive exercise
but ideally we want to work up to more
intense exercise so you're going to walk
it first and then as you graduate slowly
or gravitate into higher intensity you
want to do high-intensity full body
short workouts with lots of rest now the
p90x is a great workout but I would
extend that rest longer if you had an
adrenal problem because the key is you
could be overtraining especially if
you're doing high-intensity every day
and you're not sleeping you're not going
to
to lose weight you're going to your
body's going to turn to mush I had a
lady that did the boot camp and she was
just her whole body turned to atrophy
just skin hanging on her body and just
no tone at all so that person you maybe
should workout once a week but the whole
key is recovery okay so you can overdo
it so we started with the low intensity
exercise walking long walks every day
just get in your space not sitting in
from a treadmill watching TV but getting
out there
okay so sleep will increase lower this
and increase this so sleep is really
important there's a lot of videos I have
on sleep there's nutrition you can take
there's techniques you can do but that's
for another video but the bottom line is
we need to increase sleep I do not
recommend staying up past 12 the optimum
time to go to sleep is about 10:30 maybe
11 but don't watch the news before you
go to sleep watch a comedy don't watch a
scary movie it's going to mess up your
sleep number number three support the
gland again there's techniques I have
acupressure nutrition you can support
the clan instead of the hormone that
would be smart
avoid stress mainly stressful people
relationships that you're involved with
you know that always messes someone up I
have a gal who's stuck with this
particular individual and she can't get
out of it she's married she has kids and
she has a situation because he's not
willing to change so it's a constant
battle that messes everything up then
you compound that with menopause not a
pretty sight okay but we want to try to
do things to avoid stressful people and
situations potassium foods important
that's the leafy greens huge salads not
bananas or sugar B vitamins nutritional
yeast is the best B vitamins I would
highly recommend that these two actually
lower stress and then avoid sugar
because that will raise this as well
okay now over here intense exercise
sleeping protein does trigger growth
from them but not a lot if you have too
much it'll increase insulin which will
inhibit this so we want just a little
bit maybe three to four
bounces each meal and but we need some
proteges terian and you don't have the
density of protein it's very difficult
to stimulate growth on them okay animal
meat or animal products is the best for
this but just small amounts okay
intermittent fasting now with this one
it's not necessarily you have to fast
for days but you don't if you actually
eat all these snacks between the meals
that's messing up the liver and that
keeps the liver overworking all the time
if you did three meals a day and no
snacks that will be intermittent fasting
okay that's what I consider intimate and
fasting even if you did breakfast and
then a good lunch and you didn't eat
anything after that that would be
intermittent fasting that will increase
growth hormone but if you're snacking
and grazing yeah why because the liver
is where the growth hormone works
through so that liver is the hub and
that's connected to the digestion so
anything that is a strain on the
digestion will slow the liver and slow
this hormone so if you have a
constipation for example or bloatedness
or a gallbladder problem it's going to
be hard to raise this because growth
hormone comes through in the brain goes
right through there and doesn't always
work and then the next one is the
decreased cortisol fixing this and
avoiding sugar again will also improve
these so these are kind of the basic
things that I look at if a person wants
to tighten up their skin and lose weight
I'm going to look at all these things
I'm going to find out which one can we
implement that they're not already doing
I'm going to look for ways that I can
prove things you're doing but make it
better and these are a kind of a good
flowchart that you can use to tighten
things up and you'll see over the next
months the skin will start coming back
and the collagen will start coming back
one last thing and that has to do with
digestion if your stomach is not strong
enough as far as the acidity and the way
you know that it's not strong enough is
you get indigestion bloating acid reflux
GERD that means you don't have enough
acid watch my videos on that then you
can't break down the collagen or the
protein to be able to assimilate and
pull it into your skin that could be a
reason why you have loose key
- because you're just not digesting it
so if that's the situation you can take
something to certify the stomach and
really pull in that collagen into the
cells to allow your skin nails hair
collagen and come back and a really
acidic stomach will allow you to absorb
the minerals - especially the trace
minerals and there's other videos I have
that show about what trace minerals do
but trace minerals are basically
minerals needed in small amounts that
allow the protein to work better in your
body and that would be one supplement
that might be very helpful if you have
also hair loss and brittle nails things
like that so it's not the big thing but
it'll actually kind of assist in that
area okay so go ahead and try these
things in comment below and I will see
you in the next video